oh we're having pizza for lunch today
darn it what's the matter
Computers not working oh here let me out
let me help Heavenly Father we upload
this prayer to you this evening
delete the devil's cookies Jesus your
name Amen
hey man keep the traffic it's not work
oh hey Tracy how's it going oh my
brother I will tell you I have been lied
on I have been cheated and just called
everything but a child of God but that's
all right you know why cuz as long as I
got King Jesus I don't need nobody else
how are you fine
all right guys let's get started can
everybody kneel and bow your heads for
word of Prayer please quickly please
spirit of the Living God fall fresh on
this PowerPoint presentation this
evening
hey Tracy here's your paycheck awesome
plate now once you return to your
neighbor and say neighbor your God has
blessed B self-projection
amen amen if you have that ain't none
with God
I got Tracy I just think awful this week
a lady to talk to someone about it
move it
where
can't we just talk normally yes yes go
ahead
see you Tracy go in peace and said no
more
did you build this - you sculpt would
Tracy hug it out here
Tracy death Tracy